[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
tuesday july 26th i'm zoe thomas for the
wall street journal
the last time you switched cell phone
carriers you might remember having to
change out the sim card on your phone
it's a process that typically requires
finding something small like a safety
pin paper clip maybe the back of an
earring and inserting it into a tiny
hole and then picking out a tiny chip
out of the back of a tiny tray to
replace it with a new one
well those chips could soon become a
thing of the past replaced by sim cards
that let you activate service digitally
joining us to discuss what this means
for our phones and how we use them is
our personal tech reporter dalvin brown
hey dalvin thanks for coming back on the
show yeah thanks for having me
so start us off with some basics what is
the purpose of a sim card we've heard
about them for years but what do they
actually do yeah so sim cards the little
chips that you pop in and out of your
phone when you're switching carriers or
switching phones relay your user details
to the carrier and they authenticate
your cell phone so essentially they're
letting the carrier know that the phone
belongs to you and it enables you to
make and receive phone calls text
messages and use data on the phone
okay so now we're going to be switching
though to these embedded sims these
e-sim cards
what are the benefits of those versus
the traditional sim cards
so if you've ever had to take a sim card
out of your phone you know that you need
to find something really tiny really
minuscule to pop the little card out the
cards are so small that they're easy to
lose it's also hard to
switch carriers without going to a store
or waiting for someone to ship you a new
sim card and when you're traveling
abroad you oftentimes may have to hunt
down a local sim card so you're not
paying roaming charges from your carrier
back in the u.s so esims help alleviate
each of those problems okay so those are
all the annoyances we have to deal with
but is there anything about an esim that
makes it better i mean if i've got one
of these in my say new phone now how
will that kind of make my life easier
yeah i think part of the story about
esims is security and so esims are able
to be updated if a vulnerability is
found by the carrier
with traditional sims that's not the
case you can also have multiple accounts
or profiles on an esim so if you want to
switch between your work number and your
personal number in a single device you
can do that with esims whereas with sim
cards that's not as easy to do
what will this mean for the makers of
cell phones will this change the way
they develop the phones
if there's a futurist in you that wants
a smartphone that's even slimmer or
that's more innovative then esims help
the manufacturers get to that point
because they're smaller than sim cards
they allow
the smartphone makers to create smaller
more innovative devices it also gives
you more space if you just want a bigger
battery they can use that space from the
sim card and the sim card tray to add
space to your smartphone battery okay so
i feel like cell phone carriers are
always trying to get like a little bit
more room in it right to like make the
phone smaller and add other things that
that makes sense but what about from a
carrier's perspective i mean do they
want it to be easier for us to switch
yeah so some of the industry veterans
that i talked to
explained why a lot of people don't even
know that their smartphones have esm
capabilities the carriers haven't been
so quick to market those and onboard
everyone onto them
however apple's recent iphone se
shipped without sim cards already in the
phone and so when that happened
verizon for instance started to onboard
more customers with e-sims so
what apple and the smartphone makers are
really in the driver's seat when it
comes to pushing e-sims and the carriers
are slowly getting on board
some of the experts that i talked to
also said that
carriers benefit because they don't have
to send as many sim cards out or
the time that they would spend
helping people put some cards in their
phone helping people take the sim cards
out is gone once those esims are
embedded in your phone and you can't
take those out i just want to pick up on
one other thing you mentioned that was
security i mean are these any more
secure than traditional sim cards or
maybe even less secure since they're
activated remotely
yeah so
both sim cards and esims are
vulnerable
to bad actors
sim cards have been hacked for years now
and esims require
access to the cloud which opens them up
to breaches as well but the thing about
esims is that you can update them
over the air so if there is a security
issue
carriers or the cloud provider can patch
those up over the air through software
whereas if someone hacks your sim card
today
it's not as easy to correct that all
right that was our reporter dalvin brown
thanks for joining us dalvin thanks for
having me
and that's it for today's tech news
briefing if you want more tech stories
check out our website wsj.com
and if you like our show please rate and
review it you can do that wherever you
get your podcasts
i'm zoe thomas for the wall street
journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]
you